et font des annonces pour tous les gars
c'est un truc de fou kaki fleurs d'été
moi je kiffe quand l'heure d'été
arrivent pour je vous dis je suis en
vacances d'ailleurs castaldi il est déjà
en mode vacances qu'il a mis des
lunettes de soleil est bas c'est juste
vous le dis parce que c'est castaldi il
s'est fait refaire les yeux non mais
c'est vrai parce que ceni s'est passé
après les cent ans après la boum
après l'aller les multiples liposuccion
n'arrête il s'est fait l'écho sucer des
yeux par un lucho à il a des yeux doux
est-ce qu'on peut montrer ce que ça se
voit c'est chaud ça fait peur vraiment
ça fait pas bon on à la faute au petit
bâtard vous êtes sûr que ça va être bien
ça coûte et j'espère que ça va
s'arranger bit relève normalement dans
une petite semaine tout est parti parce
que à mon avis vous allez tomber trop
dimanche toute l'année prochaine cette
femme était d'accord à l'été est bien
géré et est d'accord mais il sentait que
vous vos yeux se sont ouverts
ah oui c'est la première fois on a
remarqué que benjamin castaldi s'adresse
le faire oui c'est vrai on était
persuadé qu'il avait les yeux noirs
parce que c'était que des super six
ils sont verts et ma femme amy ma vie
mais je ne savais pas que tu avais des
yeux verts non c'est pas c'est vous dire
à quel point mais elle avait pris pas
mes yeux
j'avais vraiment blague à part j'avais
vraiment là le gaucho dur c'est vrai la
pop us à tomber quoi donc voilà c'est
fait c'est fait ça fait écouter castaldi
vous savez le su prendre des décisions
et kastali bien entendu attention quand
même hein
faites attention non parce qu'il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui sont dans
l'écologie faites attention qu'on vous
jette pas dans une poubelle à tout et ça
n'a rien à voir
j'ai vu un gars comme ça et un écolo il
a pris magazine la bible a terminé bon
match il est tombé